Buenos días Raúl con 494 votos a favor y
solo 58 en contra la eurocámara ha
pedido que Rusia sea considerado un
estado patrocinador del terrorismo Y es
más que apoya actos a terroristas para
los eurodiputados los ataques
indiscriminados a la población civil
también a infraestructuras civiles como
escuelas y hospitales también atacando
plantas eléctricas para dejarlos
ucranianos sin luz y electricidad ni
tampoco gas en el próximo invierno son
muestras ante que Rusia está perpetrando
crímenes de guerra y también está
perpetuando actos terroristas en la
según la legislación europea se
considera terrorismo todos aquellos
actos que intenten
aterrorificar a la población civil y
también intentar menoscabar la
democracia y también las sociedades
democráticas por lo tanto esto podría
incluirse como una de las definiciones
europeas esta votación como comentabas
en cualquier caso es totalmente
simbólica porque se de una resolución No
vinculante pero lo que trata de lo que
trata es enviar un mensaje simbólico
mensaje político tal y como viene
haciendo los últimos meses el parlamento
europeo también a su presidente
ucraniano
que lleva meses pidiendo que se
considera Rusia a un estado promotor del
terrorismo y de hecho el parlamento
europeo también ha pedido que haya un
cambio en la legislación europea porque
hasta ahora solo solo la Unión Europea
puede considerar terroristas a las
organizaciones o a las personas vamos a
desmenuzar esto Esther le pregunto
Entonces qué implicaría para la Unión
Europea considerar realmente a Rusia un
estado terrorista por supuesto si se
establece el marco jurídico para hacerlo
tal y como reclama esta declaración
simbólica
si a la práctica considerar Rusia un
estado promotor del terrorismo es
prácticamente aislar la diplomáticamente
y económicamente algo que la práctica es
muy difícil que la Unión Europea lo haga
para empezar porque la Unión Europea los
países siguen importando gas a una menor
medida que hace un año Pero sigue
importando gas diamantes o incluso
petróleo también uranio por lo tanto es
algo muy difícil y también cerrar la
puerta diplomática también sería un
error Por lo tanto la Unión Europea
hasta ahora siempre ha insistido que en
sus que hasta ahora el mayor instrumento
jurídico que tienen su mano son las
sanciones Hasta ahora ha aplicado ocho
paquetes es de sanciones que consideran
que son la mejor forma de intentar
aislar económicamente a Rusia porque
considerar a Rusia un estado promotor
del terrorismo sería considerarlo un par
ya internacional algo que la Unión
Europea no quiere hacer hasta ahora en
ningún país en el mundo no ha aplicado
no ha aplicado esta sanción en ningún
momento han considerado a ru a un estado
promotor del terrorismo de hecho ha
habido también resoluciones no
vinculantes en el congreso en el senado
de Estados Unidos y hasta ahora el
estado el secretario de estado
estadounidense Anthony blinken lo ha
rechazado De hecho también ha habido
otras votaciones en los países bálticos
también en Polonia en este sentido pero
hasta ahora Siempre han sido no
vinculantes